In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarium for September 13, on which we commemorate, the Holy
Hieromarder Cornelius the Centurion, the memory of Saint Cornelius the Centurion and his
companions whom he brought to the faith, Demetrius, Evanthea, his wife, and their son, Demetrian.
Saint Cornelius lived at the time of the Apostles.
He was neither a Jew, nor of those who accepted the Old Law, but an uncircumcised pagan and
a centurion of the Italian cohort.
He was nonetheless a devout and god-fearing man.
One day, while the Apostle Peter was praying on the roof of the house in Japa, where he
was lodging, he had a vision, whose meaning he did not understand at first.
But, when men from Cessaria arrived, sent by Cornelius, who himself had been told by an angel,
in a vision to send for Peter, the Apostle understood that God shows no partiality, but in
every nation anyone who fears him and does what is right is acceptable to him.
While Peter was preaching Christ risen from the dead, the Holy Ghost came upon Cornelius
and his household, signifying the calling of the pagans.
Obedient to the movement of the Holy Spirit, Peter dared not refuse them baptism to the
amazement of those coming from Judaism.
From then on, Cornelius kept company with the Apostles.
When they fled from Jerusalem, after the death of Saint Stephen, and were scattered abroad,
he traveled with those who went to Phoenicia, Cyprus, Antioch, and as far as Ephesus.
He was chosen by Lot to preach the good news to the people of Skepsis, a city in the region
of Troas ruled by Demetrius, a philosopher who despised the Christian faith.
Demetrius tried to make Cornelius sacrifice to the idols, but he was unmoved by threats
and boldly confessed Christ.
Sometime later, however, feigning willingness to sacrifice, he was brought to the idols temple.
Scarsely had he set foot there when at his prayer, an earthquake brought the whole building
tumbling down, destroying the statues and burying Demetrius' wife, Evangelia, and his
son Demetrian under the rubble.
Learning of the miraculous safekeeping of his wife and son, who from within the ruins were
calling upon the one true God and his servant Cornelius, Demetrius rushed to the prison where
Cornelius was confined, begged his forgiveness and promised to believe in Christ if only he
were able to see Evangelia and Demetrian alive again.
Cornelius called them forth, and they were baptized with Demetrius and his whole household, soon
followed by all the inhabitants of the city.
Aunt Cornelius spent the remainder of his days in peace and fell asleep in the Lord at
a good old age, close by his tomb, a plant sprang up that healed every sickness.
When his relics were translated to the church built nearby in his honor, the shrine moved
of its own accord to a position near the altar.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.